how do i oh no i can't see the chat
that's why it's oh here we go gx quiet
pewdiepie i'm using this browser am i
gonna film it absolutely not
am i gonna film it absolutely not there
we go okay i have the chat here now yeah
i'm left here all right there we go
cool
i don't know why it it that's my
thumbnail like
awesome
thanks youtube like
i can't even take a new picture for one
either like
my phone's here and i'm like guess what
the mystery history will that's mine
this is yours
the one underneath is my thumbnail of
course it is okay we've not done mobile
live too many times so we're trying to
figure it out yeah we've done live at
home in our professional studios but um
we're about to go to the red and carpet
event to see spider-man know we all
we're about to get dressed to go so nice
and bougie yeah
um
it's kind of weird because
it's been like
a year yeah yeah i was gonna say years
because it feels like years night 2009
when was far from home 19
yeah no 18 or 18. was that 18
maybe 19. i can't keep up that's so
crazy yeah that's the covenant here's
really throwing me for a little bit yeah
that's what screws me out but since far
from home
it's been
[Music]
a long time
that's really when the that's really
when the journey started right that it
started after far from home
but then we started getting you know
rumors that hey this movie could
actually be something insanely sanely
huge it just got bigger and bigger right
and just got bigger hey i think you
snapped away i appreciate that
yeah and it just got bigger and bigger
and i mean
the you know the rumors of the other
spiderman come coming in you know like i
mean it just it just got huge and i mean
did i miss a super chat yeah i think you
did i don't
oh no thank you snap to win not the way
thank you very much yeah i mean it just
got
this movie just got bigger and bigger
and bigger and then now we're here and
it's just been such a long journey and i
i don't i didn't want it to end
the real purpose we're here we want to
give you because once we watch the movie
we can't rise we can't talk about it
it's a few days before you guys are
going to get to see it so besides a few
very emotionless reactions the best we
can do anyway we're not going to really
be able to talk about it so we wanted to
do some last minute predictions so
warren
obviously
you've read heard i've created so many
different ideas what are your top three
predictions moving into the film
toby
there's two
so you're still 100 percent
there you go one two and three the big
the big
the biggest controversy the worst kept
secret in hollywood which is right out
this window um
yeah mega flint things are super chat
can't wait either about to see it yeah i
uh
here's what i don't know and here's my
only concern
the other spider-man showing up the
ending
i i think
it would make sense if so
i'm going to say they'll go back to
their own universes at the end which
like i don't want to happen
but i i think that's what's gonna happen
uh i think they're all gonna go back to
their own universes
uh mobius studios think of super chat
it's the full movie we're literally
watching it with tom holland like he'll
be in the theater with
uh java
hello from your biggest fan in wexford
ireland hey
thanks so much to that super chat hello
back to you
and yeah um i mean i i think if you're
here watching right now you probably
know um i fully believe toby and andre
are going to be in the film
my personal belief
i think matt murdock is going to make an
appearance i
i think probably towards the final act
i'll show up maybe a little bit before
pretty much everything that we've been
reporting on here
no i i would say everything i've kind of
talked about before is what i believe is
going to happen otherwise i wouldn't
have been talking about it so much
megaflood thank you for the uh super
chat and for subscribing i appreciate it
supporting me and warren and the whole
community
i've got to say and i don't know how
much of this a prediction is what i'd
like to see
and i say like very
very softly because i don't want to see
it i'd like to see obviously the three
spiderman together the pointing meme
i think that needs to happen
but i think the way i want to see it end
is i would not be upset if once
spiderman died sacrifice himself to save
the rest it would be so heartbreaking
but that's why i would like to see i
think it would be very powerful and then
i'd like to see i would probably want
the one that dies to be toby just
because it would really affect me in an
emotional way that was the spiderman i
grew up with that was my hero yeah and
then i'd like to see andrew thrown into
the sony verse and kind of a separation
and they go their own way so sony can do
its own thing with andrew and tom hall
and stay in the mcu and they're not
still mixing it because i do think it's
going to get to be too much i think if
spiderman dies it should be
yeah i just know that the emotional
punch of seeing toby die on screen
would be so intense
but would you love hate it or would you
just hate it no i would hate it oh it
would be so intense for me to see that i
wouldn't even know how to process it
i would hate it
if i'm like bawling my eyes out tonight
that's what happened
look okay somebody's not spiderman
oh gosh i would hate that i really would
spencer
johnson
thank you for being a fan thank you for
that super chat appreciate it nikki the
great can't wait to hear my input thank
you so much tonight i will be posting uh
a reaction tomorrow morning a spoiler
free review no spoilers 100
on any channel yeah don't worry about
not my instagram nothing but
young quizzy thanks for that super chat
very excited thank you so much for us uh
watching it on thursday awesome i'm
watching it again on thursday um
we have hawkeye tomorrow i keep
forgetting about that
back home then we have hawkeye then i'm
flying to florida and he's flying out
after that and uh very busy week for us
but hey it's spider-man week and we're
better i'm excited scott thanks for the
super chat love you guys the wait is
over end game now and this has been
compared by the director as spider-man's
end game which is kind of terrifying
because a lot of people died in an end
game
but it's party time and we were just
sitting here we were relaxing after we
flew in getting ready to do the live
getting ready to go when warren kind of
looked over to me and he's like
this is it we're gonna see these spiders
[Laughter]
we're gonna go watch spiderman spiderman
tonight yeah that is so crazy spencer
hope mr thanks for the super chat hope
mysterio returns keep up the great work
thank you spencer johnson
we'll see i've heard a little bit of a
rumor but
since sony invited me to this thing i
won't talk anymore
if you know we're here you get a
textbook
this is genuine i would not expect him
to show up uh but but like obviously
he's going to be referenced since the
whole thing at the end there so uh
moises sombrano chris moore going to
watch it on thursday six villains
kingpin tombstone old venom mysterio
vulture scorpion mobius craving the
hunter rhino new venom hobgoblin
that's a lot of villains and
since your name so much i wouldn't be
surprised if one of those actually
shows up uh
i'm ready for kingpin i think we're i
think we're all ready for that now at
this point um i think i've wow okay i've
lost some stuff hold on but thank you
moises for that for that super chat
here's a good question um
when is your spoiler talk band lifting
when the movie comes out
15th
david cole thank you for that super chat
thank you so much for the support over
time i appreciate you invisible
productions thank you for that super
chat i hope i like it as well louis romo
thank you for the super chat do i think
toby ninja gonna be at the premiere
today um i don't because that's just
that's the giveaway would be great
that's i don't think they'll be there
that's and if they are they're gonna be
not gonna do this
uh ronan grant uh what is the biggest
proof i have toby i mean there's leaked
pictures
um
i mean what do you want i mean there's
so many i can't say we could do a 30
minute video on all of these i just i
just can't say it at this point uh
spider-man one thing for that super chat
you think we'll get the classic suit at
the end uh i hope i hope i hope i hope i
hope uh visible productions thank you
for that other super chat arkham asylum
games go into the prayer i'll see you
there if you see me come find me say hi
tell me who you are
absolutely first says long hair it's
hard to you'll see me i'm bouncing
around it's very hard to miss we'll both
be really excited too
uh i want to make sure i don't miss
anything in germany on friday billy
thanks for that super chat
can't wait for you you and everybody
else to see it
if i only get one question is toby and
andrew in it i think that's that's
everybody's question right yeah yeah but
i think the universal answer is yes i
don't know anybody in our space that
said no
no major
youtube channel or newsletter or website
everybody is saying yes yes and i know
we're going into this and it's kind of
sitting in the back of our head because
we don't have a official confirmation as
much as we like you'd probably say
99.999
sure
maybe even more yeah but you still in
the back of your head and i have to
credit sony for for really leaving that
to us applaud them because when the
moment comes i already have goosebumps
thinking about that moment coming i
applaud them so i mean i think that's
everybody's question but i also think
the majority of people would say yeah
that's happening so we're going to find
out tonight and we're going to get that
awesome cinematic experience that was
saved for us by sony and disney and all
that so i'm excited spoil it and we're
not going to spoil it everybody's saying
i love all the cues you've probably seen
it on twitter wear red if they're in it
or use three exclamation marks in your
title if they're in it we're not doing
any of that if it's a coincidence it's a
coincidence but we're not doing any of
that
kellen brown thank you you are the first
member of the champion hey a member
i believe you are the first use those
emotes so kellen thank you very very
much for being the first member of the
cosmic fam you guys didn't know
memberships are available now get some
cool emojis we're gonna do some cool
group chats uh discord and stuff like
that so thank you very much look down
and thank you for that super chat trying
to not to miss any guys thank you for
that rose super chat invisible
productions uh
i got kellen brown the man
j myer nearly there i'm wondering if
they'll use archival footage from other
films toby andrew peer been following me
since the game thank you so much jay um
i thought about that too we're gonna
like do flashbacks like they'll probably
be are they gonna like because tom and
toby explain you know what this is what
happened to my universe and we kind of
see a little bit yeah i was about to say
i wonder if they will have re-shot some
footage of them that would be in their
world
even if it's just like two minutes of
them like they are getting teleported
right yeah that would be really cool to
just to be in it for a little bit in the
in this amazing spider verse in the in
the sam raimi burst i'm getting a lot of
questions about venom
and i think a lot of people recently
been getting excited a lot of people
really getting out there with their
fantasies and saying venom's gonna be
the sixth member i don't personally
believe so we might if we're lucky get a
post-credit scene where do you stand
with that what are you what are your
thoughts on venom in no way home
specifically i i wouldn't expect him
in the actual film so you're thinking
maybe post credits maybe a post credit
because it's sony they can promote their
other films right and and then the other
ones
credit scene obviously there's maybe
there's a connection there um i would
not expect it um
but i would just say if you've watched
my videos and followed me
if you you kind of probably uh
that nikki the great remember my theory
about andrew garfield's web
web as2 i'm not sure i do remember that
you might have to refresh my mind
i'm getting a few members here but uh
let me address some super chat some
moisture some brown thanks for another
super chat going to wear my spiderman
costume at the movie theater awesome my
girlfriend never seen marvel movies and
taking my girlfriend to your first
marvel movie this is a pretty big first
marvel movie but hey that's gotta be
super
your boy brandon welcome to the cosmic
fam i believe brandon you're the brandon
i interact with all the time on twitter
and instagram what is up
if that is you thank you so much and if
it's not you other brandon thank you so
much as well uh pb and jen welcome to
the cosmic fan thank you for becoming a
member i definitely recognize your photo
i definitely recognize that you comment
on my videos thank you so much for the
further support of being a member
sebastian
bimbanek i hope i pronounced it right if
not please correct me thank you so much
for becoming a member i super appreciate
it oh i've seen everybody using the
thing that chris assad members you can
become a member of his channel now too
he's live right now he's had members so
this is cool i've got the spider-man
pointing at each other then i finally
got it yeah frank frank lorenzo do you
think i'm able to die i'm kind of
thinking she might man hey brandon how
are you doing
is that brendan and somebody
no different different brand different
i'll take this brandon
what's up brandon yeah so you guys gonna
wear suits to the red carpet no we have
to dress
uh it's called the premiere yeah
premiere premiere
yeah we actually have to get going guys
um we have to get dressed
uh we're going to meet up with the real
rejects
um and it's about an hour to get to them
and then we're going to go to the
premiere and
so
we got to get on i want to address just
a few more super chats that i got please
stop super chatting please because
i won't be able to
[Laughter]
teleport x tekken you're the goat you're
the go thank you so much really
appreciate that super chat appreciate
the comments your boy brandon you need
your comment your spider-man your life
right now thank you oblivion radio thank
you so much for that super chat do you
think mj and will make a cameo you know
they've really denied it and since um
emma's done was pregnant i'm not so sure
it seems like the answer is no it seems
like the answer's no but i'm really
hoping so luke dad and thanks for
another one any chance you get me a
signed poster
for postage island um i don't think i'm
gonna get that close to anybody just
because sony's like really strict on
covet rules yeah we have to be
fascinated and tested
yeah so that's that's bad yeah ryan knew
some really hope that whatever reaction
for this movie won't affect how doctor
strange is going to be i think it'll be
crazy no matter what thank you for that
super chat let me just finish up some
super chats here and some memberships
daryl vega i haven't been this excited
for movie in a while i know it this is
like it really is in game level like it
really really is talk to akinen thank
you so much for becoming a member of the
cosmic fam
super super appreciate that i i might be
caught up nope sebastian oh neck i think
i got you but if not welcome sebastian i
have a super chat antonio thank you so
much for the super chat how many percent
are you sure toby will be there we're
sitting at like 99.99
like there's so much little the only
doubt we have is because there's not an
official confirmation
but it's it's gonna happen guys like i
feel like yeah we're just basically it
really is and uh i just wanna announce
that if i missed you becoming a member i
will give you a shout out in my next
video but i think i got everybody we
have to get dressed because we have to
look the best that we possibly can for
this um thank you to everybody for being
a part of this journey it's uh
it's been pretty crazy it's i
i don't want it to end
that's not true i you know i was sitting
there like man like it's it's
this is kind of it's not the end because
obviously i'm gonna be talking about the
movie still for a while and there's a
lot i'm sure there's a lot that we're
gonna break down after right i mean we
can have live discussions and hopefully
we get some big connections to the
future that's what i'm thinking and i i
there's gonna be more spider-man movies
yeah i mean there's so much doctors
that's gonna be crazy there's so much
but i've heard stuff about dr strange
guys and that one's gonna be insane i
think that movie's gonna be gonna be
insane yeah uh kellen brown thank you
have an awesome time you guys do you
think they'll give andrew redemption to
save toby's mj i hope i hope that's what
that fault is um i really really do
raylen shelton will want to be in a post
credit scene um
maybe there's a lot of rumors right now
and that is that is definitely one of
them
um moises thank you for becoming a
member in the super chats today can't
wait for it either brandon thank you so
much
willem dafoe to be m.c norman osborne
i wish so too but we're about to find
out so
oh i'm so excited i'm like nervous i'm
really nervous it's like a nervous
feeling but um all right everybody we
have to get going we have to get ready
for the premiere start getting dressed
and everything like that make our way
over to greg greg's place from the real
rejects and then we got to start
from there go to
go to the theater and
then it begins and it's really really
crazy that we're here
so thank you everyone for the support
i think i just got one did i get one
more
then i don't want to miss anything like
right before
right before the end here what's this
baby yoshi do you think the miles
morales come anytime sooner have kimi in
this movie i think he'll be mentioned in
this movie but i don't think he's gonna
like really appear in this movie i think
that super chat
but
bow drive b if
it's only tom how disappointed will you
be not
i mean it depends on how the movie is it
depends on the movie's good right
so uh but pretty disappointed daniel
diaz mnla where's premiere at uh the
regency theater yeah
that's what it's called
so all right guys we're gonna get going
here i think i got all the super chats
if i missed any i do truly apologize i
always try to get all of them um and hey
we'll catch you with update reaction
after like right when we get on the
theater i'm going to film a reaction yep
uh all those world thanks for that super
chat so right when i get out i'm like
literally in the theater like right in
front of my film reaction so in like i
don't know eight hours from now i think
it's 10 30
p.m pst time is when the embargo lifts
look for something then all right
all right guys we love you all three
thousand woof woof fairly well i
actually don't know how to turn it off x
from mobile yep bye guys